you know this is Felix from Berlin
Germany and I want to know if the
universe is expanding faster than the
speed of light
I feel like so you want to know if the
universe is expanding faster than the
speed of light yes in a way what we see
is that distant parts of the universe
are going away from from us so fast that
we can't receive light from them and
that's not in contradiction with the
theory of relativity you've probably
heard that things cannot go faster than
the speed of light and that's true if
you're talking about two things at the
same place if I have two particles
passing each other like this in front of
me they cannot go past each other with
this speed faster than the speed of
light but since the story of the
universe is that space is expanding it
is possible for different parts of the
universe to recede from us so fast that
light cannot keep up so the answer is
yes